Speaker 1: So Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson, who has spent over a year minimizing
the January 6th Trump riots, said yesterday on
his program that he can think of no group, no
more brazen attack on our democracy. Then
when the Biden campaign asked Twitter to
take down nude pictures of Hunter Biden, which
are against the law in most states, and violated
Twitter's own policies on revenge porn. That's
what Tucker Carlson is pointing to as the most
brazen attack on our democracy. You have to see
this and then we'll discuss it. At 28 election,
Twitter did this with the help of the FBI
committing censorship on behalf of one candidate.
Speaker 2: While working.
Speaker 1: To hurt the other candidate. Now,
sorry. I'm sorry to interrupt. Already pay
very close attention to the language he uses.
And I'm going to back it up just a few seconds,
because this is critical to understanding the
propagandistic value of this by committing
censorship on behalf of one candidate, but.
Speaker 2: Working.
Speaker 1: To hurt the other candidate.
It is hard to imagine a more brazen attack.
Speaker 2: On our democracy than this,
huh? This is not how our system is supposed
to work. In fact, it's illegal. What Twitter
did is a violation of the First Amendment as
well as of established campaign finance law.
They never declared those contributions
to the Biden campaign. That's a crime.
Speaker 1: Okay. I think there are five lies
in there. It's only a 28/2 clip of which we
listen to 26 seconds. And I think there are five
lies in there. Think about the number of things
that he gets wrong and then we'll talk about the
absurdity. Bigger picture of this. There's I can
think of no more brazen attack on our democracy.
Well, I can think of one. It's January six,
which he minimized. And, of course, many other
attempts by the Trump administration over the
four years he was president to suppress speech, to
control the media, kick out Jim Acosta, all these
different things. I can think of many greater
attacks on our democracy than when the Biden
campaign said to Twitter, hey, this is revenge
porn. These are nude pictures of an individual who
did not release them. Please remove them. That's
not really an attack on our democracy. Number two,
he says it's illegal. It's not illegal
there. I mean, at this point, it's been,
what, 70 to 96 hours since the Twitter files
was released. And look at look at serious legal
commentaries. I don't see anyone even arguing
that there was a crime here. Number three, this
was a violation of the First Amendment. No. We're
talking about a private company, Twitter. It's not
about the First Amendment. The argument I think
Tucker and others are making is that indirectly
because the government told Twitter to remove the
posts, it is a violation of the First Amendment.
Of course, it was the Biden campaign, not the
government at the time. So for about two or even
three different reasons and layers, it is not a
violation of the First Amendment. Then he says,
it violates campaign finance laws. Now this
one has to be explained to be understood.
His argument. I'm being as charitable as possible.
This is the best possible argument that you can
make. His argument is removing the posts of Hunter
Biden naked was financially valuable to the Biden
campaign. Like a campaign contribution, it
would be called an in-kind contribution.
And so it was supposed to have been reported, but
it wasn't. Now you have to prove that in court.
It's very shaky. And I can't imagine you could
prove in court that arguing for the removal of
revenge porn by Twitter is a contribution of value
to a particular campaign. Hunter wasn't running
for anything, and it was against Twitter's own
policies and a crime in just about every state.
Now, let's take a zoom out a little bit. The
problem isn't really Tucker Carlson specifically,
is it? And what I mean by that is we have a system
that allows, on the one hand, Tucker Carlson,
to speak to a large audience on a set that, you
know, it looks like this is news. When you look
at this, it looks like a news show say things
that are completely baseless and meritless and
without evidence in many cases. And then if it
ever leads to a lawsuit and it goes to court,
FOX News lawyers show up and they say, this
is entertainment. This is not news. And
what he uses hyperbole and exaggeration as a tool
to do an entertaining show. And it should not be
taken literally as though he is reporting facts.
Oh, okay. Well, but because Fox News is really
going very much out of their way to frame all of
this as being actual news, as the word suggests.
That's really the bigger problem here. And
this is not me calling for censorship. I'm
not saying Tucker should be off the air. But the
problem is the having it both ways, all the time,
presenting as news. And listen, I'll be honest,
much of the problem is media literacy. The
people who watch Fox, not from a media criticism
standpoint the way we do, but the people who watch
Fox to learn things and to get news. They don't
realize that it's not news. They are the perfect
marks for such a deception. And it's an endless
circle. I mean, at this point, how many times are
we talking about it? The circle simply continues.
And the latest now is this is the greatest assault
on our democracy. What about January 6th? Never
mind. Dozens of other things that happened under
the Trump administration. Nope. It's when the
Biden campaign said, hey, this is illegal revenge
porn and it violates your own policies, please
remove it. Whoa. The biggest scan I'm trying is
could this be potentially bigger than Obama gate?
Which, by the way, I still don't know what that
is. It seems those are really the big scandals and
Hillary's emails. This is the alternative world.
Alternative universe better set in which
the modern right wing currently lives.